To figure out how to get rid of the fraction over here, let's focus on that term
itself, 2 3rd x. I know that 2 3rd x is exactly the same as 2x divided by 3. So,
it would be super convenient if I could just multiply this term by 3, since then
it would no longer be written as a fraction, and I wouldn't have to go through
this whole mess over here. I can't, however, just multiply this term by 3. I
need to multiply this entire side of the equation by 3. If I'm going to put in
anything from the outside into an equation, I need to do that to the entire
side, and I need to do it to both sides. So, I'm going to multiply everything,
both sides of the equation by 3. And it leaves us with a very pretty equation
that only has integer, coefficients, and constants.
>From here, solving is pretty straightforward. You can take a second to look at
the steps that I did to come up with the same answer as we did using the first
method, 36 over 5. Both of these are completely fine ways of solving this
problem. It's just a matter of what you prefer doing. Which kind of math you
enjoy doing more.